a order good afternoon
colleagues and welcome to this session
further session on our inquiry on the
Belfast Good Friday agreement two panels
this afternoon we're indulging ourselves
on this Saint David's day pausing their
very happy Saint David's Day to my
fellow Welsh member of the committee and
to anybody else with an interest in or
any who's lucky enough to have Welsh
blood yeah anywhere either near the
veins on a sadder note on behalf of the
committee or more somba notes on behalf
of the committee
can I just send all of our thoughts
prayers and good wishes to John Caldwell
and his friends and family after that
inexcusable and unspeakable event last
week we all say it but it is worthwhile
rehearsing
um
it was always a tragedy when the men of
violence deployed their tactics uh there
is absolutely no excuse to do so in 2023
and we wish the we wish him well and of
course hope that the investigating
officers of the psni and others
um very quickly bring the perpetrators
to Justice and let us if we can
celebrate anything at all then let us
celebrate and mark the fact that all of
the party leaders together with the
chief Constable last week were able to
gather and and come out with a joint
condemnation of this so at least that
points in the direction that we're all
facing in the same way and it's only the
the luddites and the lunatics who want
to disrupt and Destroy and the strong
message
hey we are delighted to welcome this
afternoon Lord bew and Tim O'Connor who
probably their Collective memory
thoughts and wisdom on this could
probably take us through to at least the
shipping forecast but we will uh we will
try we will try and keep to about an
hour for for each session today
conscious of time
um so gentlemen thank you for joining us
let me let me kick off if I may
um the Belfast school Friday equipment
is rightly regarded as a significant
achievement both in ending much of the
violence of the troubles and
establishing a devolved government based
on consensus in Northern Ireland
Heim
bearing in mind that we've refer to a
peace process the foundation zone of
which was the Good Friday agreement that
over time
The evolutionary iterative
notion of a process has slightly been
neglected
and the agreement itself sort of
slightly cast into tablets of stone
almost with the sort of temic
unchangeable status of Moses's tablets
of Stone River slightly earlier era
and Mr O'Connor thank you thank you very
much chairman first of all can I thank
you for the the
um invitation it's a great honor to be
here with you and the colleagues and
could I also Echo your uh your very
eloquent words about the the terrible
act last week and to send our best
wishes to the detective Chief Inspector
Caldwell and his family
um I think it's that you're you're
starting with an easy question chair
that's that's a that's a challenging
question
um I just get holiday don't worry I I
was I was a I was an Irish government
official as you know in in 19 so I
joined the Department of Foreign Affairs
in 1979 and I started working directly
on Northern Ireland in 1986 and I've
been involved more or less since so by
by the Autumn of 1997 when the
negotiations were starting
um I suppose the The View I think you
know there's the beautiful phrases
context is everything so I think by the
time we'd reached that period because I
do think we need to remind ourselves
again you know that in in the Autumn of
97 we were coming off almost 30 years
and of course our view will be will be
speaking very eloquently about about all
of this as well but we were coming off a
scenario of 3700 deaths I just did a
little bit of maths uh comparative for
what that would be in terms of say
Britain a popular you know the
population difference that would be the
equivalent of about a hundred and thirty
thousand uh killings in Britain you know
just think of a scale of that in a small
geography and your your question about
the process I suppose what we'd had in
the 30 years that starting with I guess
Sunningdale in 73-74 you had processed
attempts you know Sunningdale was was a
brave attempt but it but ultimately it
failed
um and then you know it's almost like a
decade and a bit later we had the Anglo
Irish agreement which was a different
kind of agreement and it was obviously
didn't involve the parties the two
governments
um but the big the big deficit of the
anglo-out agreement obviously was no
involvement by the parties so it was
very clear that the next stage had to be
that bringing the parties together so
but there was a other significant shift
I think that would happen and I'd be
interested in policy on this as well is
that
up to the early 90s the the strategy of
the two governments uh had been you
worked with the Constitutional parties
you work effectively with the center and
you do not involve in any way parties
associated with the the conflict
directly and that that changed and and
uh Claire's party was in John Hume were
very heavily involved in in this towards
the late 80s early 90s and changing that
so the process the process expanded
um to you know in the early 90s and by
the time then the ceasefire came around
and I suppose what I would say then is
the big difference about the Good Friday
of process if I can call it that uh
versus previous ones is that it was it
was I would say
um it was comprehensive in terms of the
issues on the table and it was inclusive
broadly speaking in terms of the parties
around the table obviously Mr Sean would
know that not not every party was around
the table but most part is where so I
think that what you have is the the
evolution of of of of of process and and
and bringing in as I say the wider and
and um I think that
um we we just about managed to get the
agreement over the line it was it was it
was very very challenging we can talk
about that but then I think your your
totemic you're testing I won't remember
there was no inevitability they were
precisely yes and there was that's a
very important point and I would say
what was the mood and and Paul was there
as well what was the mood this time 25
years ago you know March
um February March uh 98 and the answer
is that things were extremely tense and
intense and there was a a famous uh
clearance table remember there was a
famous
um Belfast Telegraph poll only maybe 10
days before where people were asked did
they expect the talks to succeed and I
think over 90 said they didn't so ex so
there was no expectation of success and
finally I would say in this contribution
I would say that therefore 4 the factor
of agreement after all of that I think
that's partly why I took on the totemic
because it was
um it was you you finally had something
where more or less just about you got
everybody signed up and I think that to
that the fundamental basis of the
agreement is obviously an accommodation
between the new the two main Traditions
obviously we've we've we've got now uh
you know a more diverse Northern Ireland
today as well
um and of course Alliance was part of it
at the time so but I would say that that
um that would be the main you know that
would be the main kind of piece I would
say thank you so
the
almost pure few we've got this over the
line everybody's signed up right let's
just
you know don't touch it because it might
break sort of thing
um recent poding numbers change and go
and polls owners we know a snapshot in
time
uh but recent poding would indicate that
a very clear compelling majority of
people in Northern Ireland irrespective
of which tradition they would would
associate themselves with would voting
support of a Belfast Good Friday
agreement
so given the fact that 25 years have
elapsed
do you think that there should be
um
more acceptance of
fluidity evolution
and the ability to reflect changes in
Northern Irish Society
it's very briefly and I'd be interested
in Paul's view as well I mean two things
first of all my old friend sadly passed
also Sheamus Mullen a great member of
this house he had a great phrase from
that time that it's for each generation
to write its own history
so that there is there is a better way
that that you know the need to be able
to evolve is certainly there and of
course it was built into the agreement
an important part of the design of the
agreement was the review clause and and
I suppose people ask me if you were
looking back if you're looking back
um you know would you have done anything
differently and and
um I think the the biggest thing I say I
would have done would would be that I
think we underestimated perhaps the the
challenges of implementation
I you know that that I recall myself
when we finally got it over the line and
then of course we had the referendum
immediately after that and then there
was a period of about another 15 or 16
months of of of uh stalemate and impasse
before we got the institutions but once
December 99 came and uh the institutions
were up and running and I personally was
sent to Arma to be the first Secretary
of the north south ministerial Council
and my job then was just looking after
you know north south everybody scattered
to their own pieces and we I think you
know we didn't actually understand that
in many ways implementation is actually
continued negotiation and and I think
that and so we have the review Clause we
did build in we did build in the the
capacity to be able to review and I said
if you combine that with with with uh
with with Shamus malin's uh victim and
the LA but on the other hand the the one
kind of caveat is that you know the the
Good Friday agreement the essence of it
is the totality how it deals with the
totality of issues uh on the basis of
accommodation and if you start to pull
up threads that's the big fear you know
you know and so that's the delicate
design challenge I think of but I think
you know that there is a rationale to
what you're saying but how do you do
that without losing the essence of what
was so hard won and I mean there's
nothing we can do about history I mean
but let me ask you to to just give a
movement's thought on this that if
um
the
underestimating phrase the afternoon if
the sort of great flare-up of the Middle
East hadn't occurred
um shortly there after do you think the
sort of review and evolution processes
would have been which then obviously
took up a huge amount of bandwidth of of
the Blair government do you think that
they would have been
more review more Evolution at an early
stage to get that embedded as part of
the process
yeah I think we have to cut ourselves a
bit of slack that because as you said we
had no experience of success we had no
experience of what success looks like in
a in agreement terms and so I think we
were all feeling our way it seemed like
the right and there was also a rationale
to let the parties you know get on with
it now uh Power sharing has been
established uh there was a bit of I'm an
old government guy so you know
governments step back now uh and and so
that was that was a reasonable rationale
as well you know so there's a there's a
fine line between uh over you know over
over interference by by governments once
you have set up power sharing let it be
so these were delicate kind of
trade-offs I think that had to be um
that had to be you know I don't know
Paul what what do you think about it
you're absolutely right I mean
everything that Tim has said I recognize
is uh has been substantive uh I mean I
do have a view that um uh you couldn't
you were never going to get a situation
where
the Prime Minister that was spending 40
percent of his time in the first two or
three years on all the other ending
things change but even up to the end of
his Premiership there was a lot of
Engagement there was a whole business of
putting together a new deal between a
dup and shin Fame because the previous
dealer in Prince or anything else on the
sdlp and structurally still reflects
their thinking now
there's a thing I remember
prior to the agreement itself there was
the framework member talking to Sir John
chilcott about as well I was very
friendly and everybody would say this is
far too complex a document and he
laughed and said and it can't people
would say to a cat bring good governance
and he would say that's not the point
the point is to bring peace and actually
that affects that's the reason now
against myself I would say that towards
the end of his life John was now saying
to me well it is time we aim for a bit
more than peace and we've got some good
governance I have to say I'm still I
would still give the same answer as
regards these structures the point is
peace there is no possibility by the way
of changing the thing that causes the
most gridlock which is cross community
veto because it's not just a question of
what the dup thinks should fame or never
agree so there's just absolutely it's
wonderful and lots of people I respect
enormously write and are written in
favor of because of the frustrations of
the last few years we need to be looking
at this it's a bit in changing this
there is actually just no possibility
that's that's important just a tedious
but real fact and it's not just because
of the dev I also think at this moment
it's unfortunate to go on about it
because people didn't go on about it
when she had been brought down the the
assembly to the same degree as they now
do when the dep have
um and I think that it it when they say
hello you didn't worry so much about
this or talk about changing the rules
When sin Fein brought it down they're
actually being entirely accurate in that
respect
it deep is a point in that respect and
the other reason why it's not helpful is
that we are not a moment where there is
at least a reasonable and certainly A
Renewed chance of the return of the
assembly and and and of getting it to
work again but I've never to be
absolutely honest it's not just peace
it's
Community Psychotherapy is the point of
the thing and I've never I'm only too
broke about I never really believe the
Devolution was about anywhere was about
better governance or there's not there
there are political psychological
communal reasons why you have to do it
throughout the rest of the United
Kingdom it's very hard to point to
results in Education Health anywhere on
the which are superior to what was
previously existent under an old style
of Westminster government I've actually
just never I do regard as a political
necessity which exists for political
reasons and in the case of Northern
Ireland the need for equality of esteem
between the two communities so I believe
anything will be worse but the idea in
principle The Evolution needs to wiser
or better decisions doesn't not just
even an old Mound I've never expected
good governance as such particularly so
I do think you have the sight of the two
leaders or two communities working
together is a top-down exercise in
helping to reduce sectarianism hasn't
cured it it definitely reduces it the
form of the governance I've just never
believed or expected suddenly
uh creatures of the Statue of Churchill
and actually are going to appear
installment I've just never thought that
was ever likely to happen and I don't
think it ever will happen but you can
have a decent
a great former government in which
people meet together and discuss their
differences and we've done it and to be
fair to the dep as well as the David
Truman's original achievement we've done
it for many years and Lord now and we
can do it again and it can be stable and
Northern Ireland needs stability so the
watch words of peace and stability that
that's that's how I see it I do not
believe in significant changes of the
structures don't be would you add us the
sort of maybe third magic ingredient
apart from peace and stability without
wishing to denigrate either
um but Prosperity yes because prosperity
for those from peace and stability and
if people feel better if their
pocketbook is feeling a bit Fuller if
their quality of life is going up of
their life expectancy is improving
there's a more far more personal
investment
in securing the retention of the keys
that unlocked access to stability
prosperity and peace I agree absolutely
and to say quite simply the promise of
this moment which I think is real enough
is that you you have the possibility not
just of a more stable Lord now that
actually works but but but
clearly that relates to investment
opportunity or people's attitude outside
to investment opportunities and clearly
there is very considerable uh promise in
this moment it may yet fail it may yet
be blighted but I agree absolutely with
the point but again that's not a matter
of structures of the assembly what
matters is your ongoing power sharing
and stability and people looking into
life so I can see this might be a place
to invest can I just now chair one yes
because I think that's a very important
discussion you're having there because
and on your own point about Prosperity
you know speaking as a as a southerner
here you know that that the past 25 30
Years also you could say coincides with
the most prosperous period in the
history of our stage yes now you know
but actually I immediately removed the
word coincidence it's not a coincidence
so the two are shall I say inextricably
linked and so you're making an important
point there building on peace and
stability so in fact our our leading
economic our our main business
configuration ibek has just launched a
new Campaign which which actually
underlines directly the the connectivity
between peace they call it for peace and
prosperity so they're expressly talking
about the interlinkage of the two so
that's a that's very so but I think I
fully agree with Paul as well that peace
and stability and I think we'll be
careful is not to not to underestimate
because the change that that was there
from the previous 30 years to what's you
know the past 30 years I think we can't
you know we just can't second guess that
I've just
17 minutes and we've done question one
so
um I uh and I I I I I I I I know about
our time constraints I'm getting now
going to turn to Bob's Church no I'm my
question is quite quick one
um the the haunt method which we're
talking about you know the methods of
government uh the sort of um Jefferson
method of Designing who the ministers
are committee chairs Etc
um I presume you would both of you
agree that it was a good thing and has
worked and if that's the case you're
both nod my question is over
I mean I I I would love for you I mean
to haunt famously was the answer to the
quiz of namely a fake pub quiz of Danny
a famous Belgium and um but
um yeah I I I I I I we we both accept
that I mean the chairmanships and so on
I mean look Stephen for example that's
where he knows a lot more about how
these things worked out in Storm but
then
almost everybody living but actually
these things worked out reasonably
fairly in store but I I I would say even
with an advisor Edward carlston I think
at one point but yeah
so we can speed up really because both
of you are in agreement the answer is
yes and therefore my question's over
we're on to questions
I'm sure I don't know if the colleagues
were there but there was also there was
a drama about it you know when on the
first day of the uh I think it was the
29th of November 1999 uh when the hunt
was Run for the first time and the way
it works the shirt is that the uh the
speaker calls first one of the party
leader you know based on the the you
know based on the number of votes Etc so
party leader has to and they have 15
minutes to respond to say you know first
of all what Ministry they're taking and
who is actually going to be assigned to
that Ministry and nobody knows then as
as that goes along what then you know
what pick number five will be
right it's all fractional isn't it yes
exactly yes yeah and you know we you can
understand but we knew we knew what that
that for instance in that occasion the
uup we're going to have the first speak
the strp would have the second I think
um at the third and dup the fourth and
so on and
um so there was a there was a power
about it there was a drama about it I
think as well which uh so Steven's a bit
fractional as well is he
sort of political equivalent of sort of
a hybrid of Love Island and naked
attractions yes there was one one year
where I've done behind it's closed doors
and worked out in advance yeah
sorry
to your point clearly the
um
imperative that both sides if one can
use that phrase
have the parity of esteem is represented
by Ministry with office and so on and so
forth
but in 25 years
the society and the linkages and the
associations of Northern Ireland have
evolved and changed
not just sort of bake in the them and us
so in reality I wanted to recognize I
remember being very upset when my
external extension for the Department I
was in Sabrina Crick wrote an article
saying Northern Ireland faces both ways
on my obsession at the time in terms of
uh was how working people should come
together and so on and transcend these
differences it is not happening it will
not happen we need to manage the the
fact that there are these two
predominant identities and still are
despite the increase in in the alliance
vote and the advantage of equality of
esteem isn't just the occupation of
first and Deputy first Minister it's the
responsibility it imposes on The
Sovereign government yes in the
international agreement and The
Sovereign government has to deliver when
the when local circumstances don't or
has to work at it there's no simple
answers to what it might be but it has
to try and in the first instance for
example recently in this Parliament we
passed Irish language legislation to
deal with to use of Praise in that in
the at the beginning of article 105 the
aspirations of the Nationalist community
and that was past here equally now the
Windsor framework respects the British
government's work to say there was
clearly alienation in the unionist
community with respect to where the
protocol was working we have now carried
like a labor of work to to to to to try
and address that so the formulations
around equality of esteem and I agree
there's a part of it which is encasing
the sectarian Dimension and for a long
time I find it very hard to live with
but in real terms it's actually the best
thing to do and it has allowed what is
not just dealing with the Irish language
for the Nationalist Community but it was
because it has affected me that has been
the most concerned about the Irish
language it is the rationale for the
United Kingdom government to say we
can't leave the Union's community in
this alienated condition in which its
identity is like all reasons identity is
related that's why so much work has gone
in for example to the white paper here
as well as the actual text of the
agreement an awful lot of workers got in
and it's on the basis of saying we have
a responsibility under the Good Friday
agreement to do this the bill was
originally defended by the government on
those terms I there is no not a real
basis for the bill because quite a large
chunk of it has actually been acted on
and so on but nonetheless there is a
labor of work carried on which which is
based on the fundamental principle of
equality of his team and what it means
and The Sovereign government
no people told me it's a joint agreement
actually the UK government has far
greater responsibility is a joint degree
of the British times it's an
international agreement but the
Sovereign government has the weight of
responsibility which the Irish
government doesn't have to actually deal
with that particular aspect of reality
and they have really really tried as
anybody can see from a text to the
Windsor fragrance so if I could just
totally agree with that that that's I
mean nor abuse touching I think now on
the fundamental because I know the focus
of your inquiry is very correctly on the
on the institutions but actually the
institutions are based on the foundation
platform which is actually article one
which which which enshrines uh these
principles you know of partnership
equality and mutual respect and article
one doesn't have a bit of a nerd now
that doesn't get the attention I think
that it deserves it we both agree we
both agreed only and you don't hear Too
Many people talking about article one
five but it gladdens my heart to hear
Paul say that because actually the
article one is made has six parts and if
you think of it six parts of a jigsaw
and all of which together constitute the
new constitutional understandings and
they are actually fundamental to the to
the way forward and article one five is
rigorous impartiality
um and uh and and therefore on on both
sides and obviously you know with with
all communities coming you know there's
a there's a a new diversity in Northern
Ireland as well but I I would like to
just totally Echo the the fundamental
importance of article one as the
foundation stone of everything that
we're talking about and I I have just
said that it is the basis for the very
difficult complex Series where the UK
government and moves it's made over the
last year 18 months
that they've been acting in response to
their responsibilities under that
agreement as they have stated a number
of times however it is complicated what
we mean by high quality with Steve and
one of the clear points is you cut I
don't think there's any reason to argue
that on the one hand you must respond to
the alienation of a community which they
have tried to do in the case of the
unionist community in recent times but
there's no point in replacing it with
the alienation of another community and
therefore to say
um
we're not going to have a hardcore we're
going to have a hard water on the island
of Ireland or we will be accessed to
special access to single Market that too
would not be in the spirit of article
one floating and treating with contempt
as so many people have done the vicious
of the unionist community over the last
year is not defensible under article one
but to take the argument further this is
why we reached the Terminus with this
document because it can't be taken
further the British government's gone as
far as it can reasonably be expected to
go to address Union to say or it is
possible to go
the idea that no we just carry on this
hasn't happened no because the point is
it can't go further
prime minister Johnson said it about the
about the protocol the point is to fix
it not to Nix it
and what that means is if you want
access to single Market which by the way
a very large section perhaps a minority
but a large sex the minority businesses
knowing that once there are certain
consequences and you cannot totally
expunge EU law so you cannot take this
principle which the Union's Community is
rightly turned to and said under the
Good Friday agreement we want our
alienation aspirations addressed as some
kind of absolute that somehow the
aspirations of the other community don't
exist uh and and so I just want to add
that that's why in some way we are in
our determinants for a particular
process a particular moment in history
is over isn't that a refreshing
um it wasn't a refreshing
um change of tech from the Prime
Minister who has who very clearly on
Monday started to talk about judgments
and balances yeah trade-offs and this
rather than
um everybody can eat cake uh no matter
how much cake they want to eat no matter
what the flavor
yeah yeah I mean this prime minister's
done but the phrase I mean to be fair
and uh because I know here in
everybody's lifts and all parties in in
my own house uh the delicate balance of
the Good Friday agreement we need to
preserve it and we're worried has not
been preserved is in Boris Johnson's
first letter to the EU that's when it
first appeared according to the
Corinthians doesn't it yeah I mean so I
I'm simply saying that it is slightly
and by the way which stood up has made
clear uh that his predecessors you know
he has completed and with characteristic
attention to detail and precision he has
completed the work which they actually
began in substance there is a
fundamental continuity in the three
private Indonesians we could not talk
about style and and mistakes made made
earlier but this the other way I see it
is the end of a moment by the way is
that the 2017 agreement uh which is an
international agreement as Michelle
Barney insisted The Joint uh EU UK
report of December 2017 was the
beginning of a of a kind of Fairly
disastrous collapse of the British
negotiating position as the Irish side
subsequently said Ireland was allowed
basically complete ownership of the of
of the interpretation of the agreement
we're ending that moment
we spent a huge amount of time on the
protocol its fathers and it's uh and
everything else but I do want to focus
uh in the time available to us
um
we're covering quite we've been covering
quite a lot of territory um already so
colleagues should feel free to sort of
uh chip in and amend and demonstrate
fluidity
um I've got Jim Shannon next or did you
want to come in on this particular Point
well I do I do because I've been
listening carefully to two of The
Architects of the Machinery of
government and I just wanted to ask
about petitions of concern we've heard
reference to them this week in the form
of the storm and break which the analogy
has been drawn between petitions of
concern and the storm will break by the
Prime Minister we know in new decade new
approach the original purpose of
petitions of concern was refocused quite
properly and there was a an agreement
that certain wouldn't be used for to
criticize ministerial conduct Etc
how do you square the grafting on of a
new process with the approach in the in
new decade new approach do you think
there's a contradiction or do you think
actually it's a reinforcement to the
cross community I mean to be quite clear
about this
the petition of concern and the the
so-called assembly break is one of the
key issues which means that uh you know
this is at the upper end of unionist
community expectation of this deal and
so it is you know I'm certain that the
previous Arrangements in this respect
create little part in the decision to
that they're going to go for this what
it means of course is that and what in
terms of the criticism the unit security
or doubts is it does depend on the UK
government so you need at this present
time the brutality reality is the dep
could not alone trigger a particular
concern because they're five I think
it's five members short with the few
ones the Union as they could
um and my point here is this
um and the people are now in all that
isn't as good as it looks and they're
allowed some dep doubters of this point
is very simple no UK government if the
assembly is up and running again and if
the if there's a real issue if it's some
trivial Point that's got up a UK
government will say wise up but no trip
no UK government in the event that there
is a serious issue at stake something of
substance of concern which concerns
significant numbers of citizens is going
to say oh we've got to where we'll get
you have additional concern we're not
going to look at this we're not going to
help this is rather more than just
what's in the document just think ahead
uh um to to what is likely to be in
immediate so the other circumstance is
that
it's not immediately obvious to me
what's coming down the pipe
either under this government or the next
is actually likely to create
circumstances for it to be triggered
actually it's not immediately obvious so
I think there is a defense regardless
it's it's totally unpredicted one of the
many things about disagreement is the
entire local intelligence media class
didn't expect this uh much of the
political class did not expect it
um uh and that's slightly a comment on
their
ingrained habits provincial self-regard
essentially which is now communally
across community in Northern very high
level of saying
um you know but nonetheless one of our
problems is the people not having
expected it insisted because I didn't
expect an account have happened you know
and that that you could quite culpably
hear that and you could read certain
journalists and so on uh um because I'm
a wise man who tells you what's
happening here and doing that and I
hadn't a clue about this or don't really
believe that believe this isn't as good
as it looks and you could pick it up and
quite a lot of what's written and said
so far in the local media yeah yes I I
just I mean I think the petition of
concern is that the whole focus at back
and Good Friday was about creating this
delicate balance across everything check
balance check balance so when I was the
Secretary of the north south ministerial
Council provided for five and a half
years I was the working with my Northern
Ireland colleagues which was a great
privilege but I had it I had a kind of a
mythical um sort of a sign on my wall
which is the college which said our job
every day here working is we manage
complexity that's what we do and that
was a kind of a principle and so built
into the design of every aspect of this
petition of concern the north I mean
meetings of the north-south ministerial
account just to give you on the design
point for instance as part of the checks
and balances and the the complexity
because complexity is your friend uh in
a conflict situation actually
um is that you you had a scenario where
um the the minister of a particular
Department was obviously either Union
internationalist in the early stages
anyway and they were so to say the
minister of Education was Martin
McGinnis so when Martin McGinnis was
appearing in the north-south ministerial
council with it with their southern
counterpart they were he was always
accompanied by a minister from the other
uh from the other
um from the other group
um and that's so that's one checking
about and all decisions of the council
had to pay by agreement therefore that
was effectively a veto by a minister so
what's that all about answer com by true
complexity and David Trimble again sadly
passed he had a great phrase that uh the
Council of Ireland would have been
regarded as what the element that
brought down Sunningdale and here we
were now operating the north-south
ministerial Council actually quite and
David Trimble was asked you know why why
the difference and he said because in on
Good Friday in terms of north south we
got the architecture right
and so I think that's a key I would say
that actually so so all of these
Dimensions they're built in complexities
which actually enable everybody to work
then and the other principle by the way
that I had my wall was no surprises
so managing complexity and no surprises
brilliant
thank you I might go and start doing
some needle points to have precisely
those things with mine Jim Shannon thank
you um first question took 15 17 minutes
this question took 20 minutes so the
wrestlers can work out the figures how
it works I was sure actually Jim you
know only saying that it's not me in the
comments what else I've been criticized
by not being pity but I realized that
maybe I am pathetic you know give us
give us a give us a favor of your pitted
us look Lord can we say what a pleasure
it is a hobby here uh and and uh and
thank you for all that you do as well
and the conversations we've had at the
airport have always enjoyed those and
thank you for them
um
Tim you mentioned that bird drama my
goodness there's always drama in
Northern Ireland you know
it never changes and I won't change
either for the future my question is um
UK government here has legislated on
several occasions on the the language
and identity building as an example even
though we and the dup put forwarded the
Ulster Scots language should be uh um
given the same equal treatment of the
Irish language uh that the government
entirely decided not to be the case and
an example of that by the way I I asked
for a frame of information in relation
to the Irish language and the Ulster
Scots been spoken that they are at the
Northern Ireland assembly in in the last
um term Irish language had 145 000
pounds spent on on that and they also
scattered one thousand now you can see
they the the the differential and very
very clear terms and it shows to me that
uh that the government unfortunately
here didn't uh I quit the same I give
the same equality that they should have
given to the languages even though uh we
put forward that case the second
occasion of course is uh is the abortion
bill which they ruled roughshod
in this place over the views of the of
elected representatives and thus of us
who have a very very strong tradition
and belief in that there
um the third occasion was when andati's
law which incidentally we all all the
collective wasn't five parties supported
uh and and therefore is an example of
how we can put something forward here
that doesn't isn't contentious uh over
what would be in a different way done uh
Robert uh made the comment about the
petition I I think it's important to
have the petition of concern there it
um it gives um
um a security or perhaps
a methodology where both sides of the
community can have if they have to and
they want to they would exercise that
right so I don't think you can ignore
them uh well I'm calling everybody else
the example Mr chairman well then we
want you to set one yeah yeah well I
thought you might
uh the the point I'm making uh Mr
Sherman which is really really important
and and and I feel it's important I
don't know if nobody else really thinks
that but that's a guess by the way
um lordly I think you've answered this
question but you put forward a very very
strict a very very clear case
and the case is that government in
Northern Ireland by its very nature to
move forward and I was part of that
assembly by the way in 1998 I I I was a
supporter of that process and the way
forward and I agreed with it because
that's the only way we can we can move
forward to have a practical process and
embrace all the political aspirations of
those within in Northern Ireland
and and it's right to say that there
probably can never be
uh what I would refer to as a majority
government like to have here even though
our majority government of course
Northern I wouldn't involve two parties
from different traditions and make that
actually happen uh would that be your uh
impression of where we are and where
where the political processes we have in
place now will always be the clinical
process that we have a majority rule
really isn't possible
it he I never say always I'm saying for
this current phase that we're in which
is a well I think a particular phase is
over between brexit they
early Agreements are now either sorting
out of the early agreements between the
UK and and and and and the EU so I think
we're at the end of what is basically a
five-year period and you know it's a
this is just a new moment decisively new
moment there are some people talkies if
they can carry on as if something major
hasn't happened that's not the case
something decisive has actually happened
and we're in a new moment and new rules
are coming into new context certain I've
been created we lived in in in in in one
set of problems essentially for five
dreary years and it's moved on not
perfectly can't be perfect but we've
moved on as well as statesmanship can
make it move on so yeah I would never
say never as still a part of me which
harks back to the idea that you know of
non-sectarian politics
um you know to which I wrote a large
part of the 1970s and 80s too
um but I you know
brother Creek was right I think so it
does face both ways it is hybrid
and the son there's just no getting away
from that and currently now that's a
clue to understanding why you cannot say
it no tincture of EU law because I'm a
union any more than there are there are
there are EU Lord junkies in Belfast who
are absolutely high on the supply of EU
law and any more that you can you can
you can start addressing the unionist
community from that perspective so I
just think irreducibly that's what they
are it faces both ways there's
inevitable hybridity of this hybridity
of society actually both unionists
accept that the question is the terms
and for the last five years it's been a
perfect and fair argument which
um essentially the UK government has
accepted and now the EU has to a very
considerable degree accepted that these
terms were not in balance
for as far as going down is concerned
and we're now in a new place it will
never be a perfect balance
I think the aspiration to have a
majority rule me my former leader Peter
Robinson always and as he led the party
some time ago but he always was a
um
suggested perhaps that always be
suggested that perhaps someday there may
be a majority rule that that processor
political process could be wrong I
probably really subscribe to what you've
said and released or not uh and I I'm
not sure if it's possible I think that
the answer just add I agree with
everything that Laura Pierce said I mean
I think that the um but but you're right
it's it's really it's ultimately it's
about trust and confidence isn't it and
um this agreement you know back 25 years
ago was was based on coming off the back
of of 25 30 years of conflict that
caused such death and destruction so
trust was was didn't practically didn't
exist and therefore you have to put
together structures
um in the absence of trust and trust and
confidence and that's why you know when
we were you know the principal of no
surprises and and and all that no
eventually I I won't say but one
unionist Minister said to me one day
after a meeting at the north south
ministerial Council which we had
carefully managed so that there were no
surprises he said we could have done
that meeting by email you know because
because it was so choreographed I was I
actually took that as a kind of a good
sign that we could actually start
removing some of the um
um but but of course there so I suppose
you're you're the you're the politician
Mr Sanders so I I guess it the call is
whether you know at a political level
the level of confidence is trust is
there uh that you could move to that and
then of course I just add in Sheamus
Mullins great you know dictum that it's
for each generation to write its own
history so as Paul is saying you know
maybe the time will come but it's it's
not there at the moment I wouldn't think
that's a perfect question thank you Jim
thank you Mr
condition no surprises and I think
running through
um all of your both of your answers this
afternoon and indeed all of our
questions
is the basic assumption that it's the
electorate who deals the hand of cards
as the politicians who then decide how
they're played
but it's the electorate who decides who
their representatives are going to be
I'm going to guess here that you would
concur with the proposition
that the architects of the Good Friday
agreement and all of those who have been
custodians of it subsequently
would have subscribed to that view that
in any electoral process it's the
electorate who are King
so should is it a surprise
or possibly a shocking disappointment
that we find
one party uh in Northern Ireland it's a
small party but it's a vocal party
who appears to be saying
we will only support this institution
if the electorate give us
the result that we want
and we've heard recently there's been
Clips in social media which is you know
we will never put in a shin Fein
first Minister but if that's what the
electorate have voted for the numbers
are there
should be we should be surprised shocked
or disappointed that people who stand
under the banner of
democracy and and let me just be
absolutely clear I mean Jeffrey
Donaldson I think has been perfectly
clear that he'd be perfectly happy to to
do this I I I think the dup's position
is clear and and is and and is
supportable and is laudable
um but for politicians to then tell the
electorate you got it wrong
shocker was surprised with
disappointment
one
because I could say I was shot a
surprise but I basically think it's not
not even remotely realistic happily I do
not believe for a minute that is the
position of the dup no it's not no no
um what I would say
could I just add something let me just
be absolutely clear because I said I I
think no no I I understand I understood
you exactly what you're talking about
and I did want to add something to that
um
you
things really if this is all right one
is that we are moving before too long to
the the major change between the May uh
iteration of the agreement which did not
even mention the Northern Ireland
assembly so this shows how major the
labor has been to deal with the
Democratic deficit and the changes that
are now in place now at the Johnson
withdrawal agreement does give a realtor
and it does mean there will be a vote
assembly on the protocol so we are
heading down the road before very long
to a democratic vote and at the moment
most people assume that particularly
with these changes it's a very
substantive changes there is there'll be
a consensus yeah and certainly a great
majority of the people who know now
judging by their lecturer who wants to
accept that and I wonder do people fully
realize that we've passed a very
significant moment that if you know
there is no end endless replay of these
arguments available because eventually
there is there already is a very
considerable closure I would just say I
don't want to pass here but just to
understand the reason why some of these
arguments TV events on have got Leverage
is that
things were said by an Irish leadership
which were unwise so they don't have to
misquote things that were said in
2016-17 uh you know and uh in the
argument and I understand Ireland's
position Ireland thought brexit was a
huge threat to their real and legitimate
interests and almost anything was
justified to in terms of political
process to defend their position so I
understand how it happened and there's
no point in revisiting it but things
were said they do not have to invent the
people in that neck of the woods
politically quotations which were unwise
and look very bad today from Irish
political leadership it's only right to
say that because they haven't got fuel
from you know it doesn't just come from
nowhere that there are places such there
are things that have happened which
which have gener which unfortunately are
part of the historical record it still
doesn't matter because your point is the
overriding point which I fully accept at
this stage there is a question of the
democratic will of the peoples of
Northern Ireland I can put it like that
and we're very close to a definitive
test on that and how do you carry on
this argument after that yes
I do want to do you realize too much
because I think there there are I think
there's too much focus on on what I
would characterize as the lemons did it
narrative because I think the the the
arguments against uh removal from the
single Market weren't just about uh the
possibility of of of of on rest and
dislocation they were primarily economic
uh and and practical but if if you are
placing the focus on on on uh comments
by the Irish government
you know was it not the chief Constable
at the time was it not I believe with
this committee perhaps MI5 and others
who who set out
um the possibility of their being
um uh disaffectation up to and including
problems I'm just not sure about why the
emphasis on the Irish government and
others the same thing and I think it is
it is a demonization strategy but
nonetheless it is true but I said that
that if you're Jamie Bryson doing
that and said exactly the same thing you
don't have to say
that's what I said you don't have to
invent these quotes uh uh which don't
look great in retrospective it's as
simple as that and if we want to
understand why we're in a mess that is
unfortunately and I've also said I
completely understand why the Irish
government are basically brexit was
destabilizing for Ireland and I
completely understand why they hunkered
down with this you know in the way that
they did so I'm not doing it I'm not
saying this to kind of raise problems of
the Irish government I'm trying to say
that there's a problem of political
management here for the Democratic Union
disability emerging their Community
which is not all a fault of their many
inadequacies in the Democratic Union's
party they are confronted with a mood in
their Community which has been to sub
degree created by others that's that's
simple but it does take him miss
Hannah's point he does Stoke of fire
does it not if a whole range of people
cross boundaries and borders have said
broadly albeit in maybe different terms
and using different language but it said
broadly the same thing
but then one only uses the gobbits of
certain sources uh to augment an
argument I mean that's true that I I
accept that but what you
you know this is Northern Ireland and I
mean it is also the case that you can
raise uh uh you know if I I actually I'm
trying to observe because I think you're
quite right this business of not
revisiting the past the reason why but
you could raise a whole number of other
things for the things that have been
said by Irish ministers which don't have
the contextual backing which uh Claire
has rightly given today so but it's not
the game I want to play well what I've
tried to say is there is a problem of
political management for the Democratic
unionist party in their own Community
which is not simply a problem not simply
a fault of mistakes they may have made
but a mood that has been created by
forces uh this this is not going to be
the worrying thing about this and the
white paper for example which is an
exceptionally detailed argument and
should be read more widely it seems to
me I know now that it is in terms of its
arguments the worrying thing is that
people will not decide enough on the
base of the content of the deal in front
of them which will have some flaws by
the way they will decide it on the basis
of communal balance communal rhetoric
things that have been said which poked
them in the eye that's the really
worrying thing and that's what I mean
and why I'm saying what I'm saying is to
respect the task of political leadership
which is not an easy one for the dep at
the present time because there's a
sourness in its Community which is
outside outside the the
um the the the the actual issues that
are dealt with in the Windsor framework
I mean just to add something on this
which is very important people say why
do people carry out the attempted part
of the last few days and it's
non-political and it's just the joy of
killing and so on and I respect those
who believe that there is a very good
reason why people do it they expect just
as people saying the IRA no uh in in
mainstream locations and football teams
or whatever they expect that the people
who did it expect that they will be sung
about in similar terms 20 years from now
that is why they do it that they they do
not do it just for helicopter
particularly cruel people or whatever
they do it because they expect
retrospective validation of of their
actions that's why they do it and that
again the fact that these mainstream
events have happened uh in terms of
mainstream Irish culture means that you
have a saring of the public mood quite
outside the details say in this white
paper which makes this harder to do to
do what has to be done has to be done
here but you know but I I just I think
you have to acknowledge the series of
the tasks and realize we're not in a
world where it's just going to be people
looking through the Windsor and saying
oh I agree with pay that yeah 38 not 39.
we're not in that world
thank you very much I mean this is a
very interesting discussion I I'm I'm
here in a personal capacity of something
representing the Irish government
obviously but I suppose the only my
comment back to to Poland that's these
are it's a very powerful argument I
think what we can all agree is
everybody's entitled their view on on
every matter
um we can all agree I think that that
certainly brexit was a as as one Kylie
described it a major disturbance and the
force you know to use Star Trek and and
I was brought up on you know the the
human doctrine of the two governments
basically it's the two governments
working as coal Guardians and certainly
25 years ago so I think one of the one
of the tremendous as was dislocations
that happened after 2016 was was this
was this Divergence of interests of the
two governments and and the inability to
and thankfully know where we're we're
back in in a scenario much more now and
where where the two governments working
together that's a core Doctrine here of
of everything a positive that's been
achieved in the last you know 50 years
starting with Sunningdale and then
um so I think that that we need to get
back to the two governments work because
they they have this common interest and
I suppose you know in terms of the what
happened last week you know we have to
remind ourselves that the the primary
reason why we had a peace process was
was precisely to end the killing and to
find a way against the backdrop of you
know the famous A Faulkner will um
William Faulkner quote history is not
dead it's not even past and and here so
so this is this this has so trying to
find a way to break that that that's
that was the achievement of the
agreement and I I totally I think Paul
is making a very important point when
he's saying that actually to keep our
eyes on that prize the primary goal of
Good Friday was was peace and stability
and uh it has it has a it has achieved
that demonstrably not totally
um and now the other pieces have to
follow but I think at the core of that
is the two governments working together
and hopefully we're we're on that track
now again which I which I deeply welcome
thank you
um
the designation of other
suggests and I heard I think we all
heard Lord be your
answer to the to earlier questions but
other suggests
foreign
Beyond description almost isn't it other
um
we know Society is changing we know the
older for the oceans are looser
uh than they were in a large swathe of
uh opinion the
um
diaspora of Northern Irish youth as soon
as they get sort of qualified go away to
University
to GB or else when didn't come back Etc
suggested growing sort of anxiety and
tension about all of that
notwithstanding the need the absolute
important need to reflect in how the
institutions are founded and based
how does one
evolve
good fight agreement the institutions of
Stormont the strands Etc to reflect
the other and to actually find a better
word for other
which as I say all from the start
suggests alien different and Beyond
description
first of all I absolutely accept other
it's you know spot up I I we and there
must be on the middle because
to do better not aligned we could use
couldn't we yeah I mean I I'm absolutely
with you on that chairman can I say
something
it's important to understand that while
you have these two blocks
actually they have liberalized
dramatically and I mean the dep block
admission fee block both of them no
longer believe things that were
mainstream beliefs in their party
two years ago so the idea that what
we've got is a system unmarked by
liberalism doesn't actually understand
the pervasive strength of modern liberal
secular society even within the dep I
mean and even within the Republican
movement which in his own way for a long
time was a
concealed little world of its own so
while I totally accept your point and
the other is is is is is is is an ugly
term I'm totally with you on that the
nonetheless the the the way that we are
going in Northern Ireland people
shouldn't look at these blocks because
they're internally changing quite
dramatically as being a stasis or a
stainless necessarily they are already
unrecognizable I didn't think and I was
quite wrong one of the reasons I was so
committed to what David trim was trying
to do is I didn't think the dup would
pick it up and work it uh because I
believe that there were so set in their
ways it's a nonsensical assumption on my
part I was totally wrong and I'm just
saying it in general
people do not realize from outside how
far things have have actually how far
things have actually changed within the
two major parties in Northern the dep
and Shinn Fein and the Tendencies of
thought within them are much more
complex than they once were so it's not
quite as rigid and sterile and they have
possibly have they have the price for
them both is in a situation I think in
Belfast 10 of the people were born there
something of that certainly high that
the price for them is in the future now
whether either of them can actually
generate support I do not rule out that
both of them are capable of inflexible
enough to generate support from the
communities the 10 of Northern Belfast
people are not born in the place for
example they're not real do not rule
that out at all if we get stability
there's just very briefly chair as well
you know to add to that there's
um
the agreement itself also though
provides for Beyond other it actually so
just to go back to article one five that
polymers have bought me refer to uh if
you could just indulge me briefly it
says affirmed of whatever choice is
freely accessed by a majority of the
people of Northern Ireland the power of
the Sovereign government for
jurisdiction shall be exercised with
rigorous impartiality on behalf of all
the people in the diversity of their
identities and traditions and then it
goes on to say a Freedom's
discrimination for all citizens so there
is there is a totality piece as well
they're recognized now then at other
points it does talk about the in a sense
the Primacy of of the two major
Traditions but there is a nod to
um you know to full diversity but yeah I
agree with you there's not
um but should it be more than yeah I
mean yeah I also as as legitimately an
opportunity question is there a risk do
we think
of people who would describe themselves
who who have to identify as other today
because that's the word that's there
that they feel second or third class
that the uh their vote and their views
are not reflected by the architecture
the foundation stones of the
architecture and therefore why bother
why engage
is there a risk of people opting out if
if if the perennial
compartmentalization yes continues I
mean again it's back to the question of
complexity and as opposed to the the
easy stuff the the the your own terms of
reference for this inquiry are about the
design you know and so back to the
fundamental question what was the design
question posed answer it was a
contestation between two political
philosophies but that was the which of
course was was being expressed in
political violence that's that was the
essential question we were trying to
solve uh and and so therefore in a sense
they they the the plural plurality of
the agreement is is is is addressing
that but you're but but that does leave
the question that you're rightly asking
well what about everybody else so it's
that that's a challenging design
question I think that how do we how do
we how are we going to be realistic in
tackling the core fundamental
contestation of two political
philosophies sharing the same small jar
photography and how do we address that
and at the same time not not almost
codify sectarianism which is another day
um yes and at the same time but that's I
as I say the design challenge of of
complexity
and I agree with Tim and uh take the
force of your question chairman but just
to be of some comfort there is no style
at the moment that people who consider
themselves other are discouraged from
voting yeah it's quite you know and just
at this moment now I accept that this
should be kept under review
and this is the secretary of state right
he said it to this committee he'd sit it
on the floor of the house that he stands
ready to respond to a bit of Grassroots
initiatives
by that I think everybody's broadly
translated that as meaning if the
parties of Northern Ireland knock on the
secretary of state store and say
we have to do something other than other
um is that the right approach or or
should this be more of a case industry
Westminster Dublin leading a review on
it
well I mean in a narrower sense of
course he has just done with respect to
that his law exactly what he said uh he
he would do in bringing it here and not
letting the issue get stuck in the mud
yeah uh um so he has done that no it it
comes back to my my my simpler point
just at the moment people talk about the
dup and their veto on these institutions
which I hope will be ending before too
long uh the the but the um because they
have effectively
a rare thing in politics had a campaign
and got a result the the the the
um and then not a perfect result but
it's good a better result than was
generally expected uh but it is Sinn
Fein as well Shinn Fein will not
tolerate any significant change in these
current governmental structures you just
you know I I know imbalance in the
discussion people really are missing
this completely they will not tolerate
anything that we can change it in in
these structures very briefly any any
Merit in joint first minister
oh well look everybody there's Agony in
my husband and yours it's got to be
unsorted everybody could see that this
would a potential way out of a big
problem
um to be honest if I was to say
what I think something we did get wrong
in 1998 and that David got right I think
it should have been a joint first
ministership from the start it actually
is
there right from the start
um I think if we were having it I think
realistically if the agreement was being
signed today it would be joined first
Minister and I think if I was to say
there was a mistake in the original
structure that would be the one I'd see
um there was you know everybody who's
sitting here now he's knowing what the
general election could uh both in your
house and in mind and and tremendously
tempted to say let's just avoid all this
don't do it now it will by the way I am
quite confident to happen over the next
few years
because the pressure from all the
parties towards it and in this instance
now the dup and it was the dep's choice
it was deep old strategy towards
electoral changes in Northern Ireland
which underpin this because they
wouldn't be in this position if they
still had David Trimble throws was the
Union's voting block is larger but they
now have to and this is this is where
you have to be take your you know be
adult politics these are your rules to a
very considerable degree agreed with Jim
Fain
um and it's a embarrassing but you lost
under them and you have no choice in a
sense if I can put this but to say well
that's it and anyway it's a go
Premiership there's actually no loss of
any material part and by the way the
grace and dignity show
by such a move by the dep will have a
significant effect on the Catholic
Community a part of which believes
unfairly in my view that they're only
they've really got a problem with this
protocol at all they've got a problem
with ever having with having a I should
I shouldn't paying first Minister and I
believe that's unfair so that there is a
there is a it you know and in this
occasion there's a great great advantage
in what looks
somewhat embarrassing just by living up
to your own word on these matters but in
the longer term for co-prem it is it's
hard to justify having a co-preneurship
which doesn't call itself a
co-preneurship it's something that
Brendan O'Leary
academic colleague has been saying for
25 years he was right 25 years ago and
it's right now
um it's my view thank you
um
nobody has waved at me to come in on
further questions I'm conscious at the
time my Lord gentlemen Mr O'Connor can I
thank you oh Claire just different
a leader I guess oh no I I thought I was
already on on your on your right yeah
just on that that issue of of potential
um
uh rearrangements of of some of the
protocols obviously there's
um
mechanisms within the agreement for for
for review and for
um good reasons and bad people haven't
wanted to open that up and I think
particularly
um at the mood over the last year I
would have had concerns as with others
about the potential to that that it
wouldn't be sort of Keyhole surgery that
it might be something um less targeted
um uh and and hopefully uh the wolf will
be gone from the door if we're back out
in a few weeks but how do you think that
should be uh best approached
um uh to to to look at some of the
protocols and some of the arrangements
you're correct and to point out Lord
view that there there certainly wouldn't
be consensus and there would be active
resistance to evolving them from from
some quarters but what do you think is
the appropriate way and to pursue that
and we know that citizens assemblies are
kind of both in Vogue and and and have
demonstrated success
um in in the South do you think this
would be the type of discrete issue that
that could be usefully
um
he's died in that way all right good
question I I think we're you know
hopefully if we can move forward over
the coming period uh and everything and
get get everything back up and running
again
um I you know I think then there will be
a question at some point coming up for
and it the the the the review section of
the agreement talks about you know that
when difficulties rise but I think it's
a political judgment clear for for the
two governments of the parties together
to decide
um you know has a moment come where
because it it isn't it isn't written
down you know exactly how that gets
triggered uh and I think people will be
for the reasons you've just said I think
there'll be nervousness at one level uh
about doing that but but at the same
time it is provided for us so I think
that's going to be a big political
decision that lies ahead yeah and there
is a back to Shameless malin's point you
know it's it's for each generation to
write its own history question therefore
to anyone generation later is this a
moment to do that but it's a fine
political call that you're going to have
to make you know the two governments and
yourselves and the parties are going to
have to have to make together but it you
know it is it is definitely it is
certainly irrational but it's a big
political call
I'm I I basically disagree with Tim on
that player I see what your why you
asked the question
thank you right really now nobody else
has caught my eye uh so that is to the
good can I thank you both again thank
you Paul
your time thank you everybody thank you
for taking our questions right if you
want to stay for the second panel you're
very welcome I can understand entirely
if you wish to
um in the words of why don't you go off
and do something that's boring instead
but you know what I mean
um
[Music]
and Mr whistle thank you so much indeed
for joining us we're very grateful for
you for coming
um we look forward to what you have to
say and you've heard some of our line of
questioning and you would have heard the
answers and I noticed some nodding and
some shaking and I noticed some raised
eyebrows so
I'm not going to ask you to give the
rebuttal to what you've heard in in sort
of opening uh opening evidence
but can I just ask the three of you and
I'm conscious with a tripartite panel
that pithiness becomes ever more of a
prerequisite
um just for your general overview if
possible as to the relative strengths
and weaknesses
of the formation of government rules
that we have uh governing Stormont
um especially when compared to
majoritarian forms of governments such
as Westminster
nice doctor go on then why not you're in
the middle
I mean I I think when we're judging
these institutions
this is something that Kathy Gormley and
also said a few years ago one of our
public Publications
depends on the yardstick that we're
using for performance
that that determines the the kind of
judgment and I think
there is a lot to be said for to hunt in
terms of its inclusivity
it's very simple we run it
um
one of our mlas come to the assembly and
you have your executive formed like that
and in some other power sharing contexts
it can take weeks or months to form a
government so
there's something to be said for to
haunt in terms of its Simplicity and the
speed at which we get a government
and there's also something to be said
for in terms of high representative it
is in this is something that we touched
on myself and one of my colleagues Jimmy
pie who's at Queen's University we had a
kind of many citizens assembly on
institutional reform about a year ago
people particularly in a divided Society
they like the fact that our coalitions
are very
representative of the different
political traditions in Northern Ireland
but clearly there is a trade-off between
inclusivity and efficiency and
effectiveness
and the more parties you have in a
coalition the more difficult it becomes
the coordinate it in a cohesive fashion
so
it's very very difficult to achieve
Collective responsibility in a Northern
Ireland context
um
that's not to say that
our coalitions haven't worked I think
during the pandemic the first few months
of covert demonstrated that large
multi-party coalitions in Northern
Ireland can't work
um under difficult circumstances in
those first few months I thought that
the the executive performed reasonably
well and then there was a public opinion
poll I think in June or July of 2020
that was covered in the Irish news that
showed that two-thirds of the people in
Northern Ireland thought that the
executive was handling the pandemic well
and that was a good news story because
there was other governments that weren't
these large multi-party coalitions that
weren't getting that kind of press
but then towards the end of the year the
wheels started to come off on ministers
were disagreeing with one another almost
in public about public health
regulations you had use of this and
Andrew's veto to override the health
minister so we saw in that year the best
and the worst of to hunt if it can work
but it's very very difficult to work
so if we take no abuse point that
Devolution has done some things but it
hasn't led to a qualitative uplift in
terms of political outcome for the
electorate
um
would a executive versus opposition
potentially address that and deliver
improved
policy outcomes or is it just or is
there sort of
acceptable strength I suppose in this
continual finding of a balance which may
mean that the optimum isn't actually
arrived at but it's something which
nobody
shouts and screams about and therefore
the sort of the middle way is always
identified
I'll say something briefly and then I'll
pass on to my colleagues I think
because our executives are
um
so large you know with the hunt everyone
and underground mother gets to be in the
government
um we tend to judge them
in terms of whether or not they survive
and when the Mandate lasts the full term
there's kind of muted Applause that it
has lasted and I think that means that
there's less focus on public policy
outcomes and less focus on
whether Manifesto pledges have been
implemented for example and if the
executive was more streamlined and you
had fewer parties in the executive I
think you would see a stronger focus on
policy and on honor comes as it happens
you know the most if we're judging
governments by being cohesive and all of
the ministers singing from the same hem
sheet one of the slickest operations we
had was the two-party Coalition between
champion and DEP very short-lived it was
engulfed by a scandal after about seven
months before that well a few handles
but before that it it was a very slick
operation in terms of those two parties
working together and they did seem to
shift the focus of away from not just
the party's cooperating to delivery so
there is something to be said for a
streamlined executive in terms of a
stronger focus on on public policy so
just before you leave that by definition
therefore if it's very hard for people
to say no to anything
and much easier to say yes but with
various degrees of gradations of volume
in the saying if yes
um does that lead inexorably to a
compounding of budgetary problems
and and and and and the likely overspend
because one one group or another has a
great idea and I've said yes to the
other three so I've got to say yes to
him and or her and therefore spend spend
spend spend in order to placate I think
so I I think because there's
the first Minister and Deputy first
minister they don't have any power or
authority over any of the other
ministers so they can promise the world
and there's no consequences for that
unless there's a it's very difficult to
remove a minister from Office you can if
there's a kind of cross community vote
but
ministers can operate their departments
kind of like silos and promise a lot
um
and I think that we can't relate that to
the structures of the system of to to
the hunt
um but I know political Futures it's
something that was released in Ireland's
um submission have looked at things that
could be done better to focus our public
policy making more on outcomes and
budget and so on Segway is supposed to
be pretty well yes as paulview was
saying you know the the the the the real
the the first issue that had to be
tackled the agreement tackled was
getting an acceptable form of government
and that depended then on a high
leveling of inclusivity and I think it
still does now you could argue whether
the given changing voting patterns the
way Society is moving whether the rules
are exactly right but we are I think
going to have to go on having a a
government that that brings in support
across the community one of the things
that that particularly worries me about
that though is that the the absence of
focus on good government and in 1998 you
know we we did not think about this very
much at all I think we probably allowed
ourselves to be lulled into the feeling
that if we got a an inclusive government
established and with all the Good Will
from all around the world that was
coming in it would do it would do heroic
things in government terms it has never
quite worked and a great deal of reform
has been blocked in it's never entered
particularly into the culture that we
have to do government well so I'm the
last executive never established a
program for government at all you know
you have this system thrown together by
an algorithm uh people with no necessary
ideas in common they're supposed to come
together around a program for government
and then then work on that but it it
hasn't entered in the culture there's
never been
public or political or media attraction
behind those sorts of processes and one
of the things that I think needs to be
this this needs to be addressed because
it leads to the executive constantly
under delivering and you know you look
at the state of the Health Service now
but also infrastructure productivity so
many things uh we we we
need help devolved government can be can
be re-established in the near future on
the basis of the protocol but that will
not suffice
to deliver stable Effective Government
and so we need to think more
in those terms just to say in general
terms it's very welcome we're having
this discussion because
the discussion of the of the
institutions is not very fashionable and
thought to be sort of rather geeky yeah
I think we're all people who think
geekery is uh is uh is heroic and and
absolutely essential to to the public
well-being so uh glad this discussion is
being a new sort of superpower geekery
well absolutely yeah well you know the
revolution of the Nerds in Silicon
Valley and yeah we're superheroes
wherever we go really
um but it would be be nice to see this
discussion being continued after your
deliberations whichever elicited quite a
lot of valuable uh written Community
contributions I think
yes thank you um can I start off most by
saying that I'm perhaps the odd odd one
out in this panel by not being primarily
an expert on Northern Ireland so I'm an
expert on Democratic institutions and
public attitudes towards Democratic
institutions uh and that brings me very
much to thinking about Northern Ireland
uh and I've done some work recently on
Northern Ireland
um because it is important as Alan is
suggesting there that uh those of us who
are not primarily experts on Northern
Ireland engage and think seriously about
what's happening in Northern Ireland and
and how the system can work as well as
possible in answer to your question
um I don't disagree with anything that
the others have already said
we go we we uh geeky a political
scientists refer to the northern Irish
system as a consocational form of a
system and a consocational system is
used and is necessary if there is a
divided Society so a system in which you
have power sharing and guarantees for uh
different communities
um consocational systems are hard to run
it is very tempting I think for those of
us
not brought up in
a divided society and not used to life
in a divided Society to want to imagine
that it's possible to get past the
difficulties of a consociational system
um
but it's necessary
in a divided Society there are no
shortcuts to successful Democratic
governance in in a divided society and I
agree absolutely with what was said
earlier in what others have already said
that the evidence seems very clear that
Northern Ireland remains a very divided
society and therefore at present
it is necessary to have this very
frustrating complex system of power
sharing let's just pause there for a
moment because divided yes now you can
have you can have peaceful Division and
then you can have violent division media
you know we're all aware of that and
there's been a a long transition and
we're running an inquiry in parallel to
this uh with regards to the continued uh
presence of paramilitarism and organized
fragments on and so forth so none of us
are naive on this particular point but
when and who
identifies the time when one stops to
say
we decide we we design this system
as a principal vehicle to deliver peace
and that has broadly held
and nobody seriously contemplates a
return to inverted almost the bad old
days closing voted commas
we compound the northern Irish
exceptionalism we
hold on in sort of folk memory to the
bloodied divisions
and perpetuate them
in the modus operandi of governmental
information that we have today
in your experience when do those
societies
make that psychological change to say we
needed this straight jacket
to stop us shooting each other or
chopping each other to bits or blowing
each other up or whatever we don't need
that anymore
we need something else it's a very good
question it doesn't happen suddenly
it doesn't happen in one jump and
sometimes it happens without people
particularly noticing
so sometimes the institutional change
happens not through a formal
institutional change but simply because
certain institutions that have been put
in place gradually decline in their
relevance and they are used less over
time they seem to be less important over
time and eventually you think gosh that
that thing
it's not really being used anymore
um and you know so the theory of
consociationalism was developed first in
the Netherlands
because the Netherlands was a very very
divided Society we don't think of the
Netherlands is very divided Society
um but the system just kind of gradually
changed and how in practice it
functioned
uh it wasn't that someone suddenly
decided okay now we don't need to have
consocationalism anymore it just
gradually changed in its function so it
seems to be I mean you're absolutely
right that there are dangers that some
things become entrenched and yes become
barriers to society moving on
um but it's also the case that some
elements will kind of evolve away
naturally and I mean it seems to me
looking at
uh the situation currently in Northern
Ireland and so a lot of my thinking on
this is based on some focus groups that
we ran last summer when we we explored
in depth
um how people
how Ordinary People in Northern Ireland
uh think about these issues it seems
very clear to me that the kinds of
sectarian concerns that led to the
creation of those institutions 25 years
ago are still there and and need to be
respected and need to be understood
not sure
briefly I went to Mr Walker yes Dr hogi
No Doctor yes okay just
agree absolutely with with honor and
he what we we talk about that in
political science circles is the exit
dilemma and I think the committee had a
written submission from doctors Joanne
McAvoy and Allison McCullough and
Allison has written about the exit
dilemma and power steering systems in
some systems as as Alan said
the mechanisms become used less and less
and the system kind of evolves and
changes and grows it looked like that
was happening with our system if you
think about the reforms that happened at
the petition of concern with new deck
and new approach and then it never got
used again so the restoration of the
evolution the last time seemed to be
about suppressing the petition of
concern now we're talking about the
restoration of the evolution and crucial
to that is interpretation of concern
yeah so swings and rounds about
yes Mr Walker I just really really
interested in this
um addressing this dilemma and certainly
a few years ago there was a general mood
that um you could continue with a degree
of consocial amazing and the
arrangements and the balance in place
whilst also developing a stronger
opposition within
um Northern Ireland are there other
systems that you've studied where that
has it has been been able to be
developed in terms of being able to
develop maintain a balance between
divided communities and and build up the
role of uh an opposition and of course
there have always been parties
represented in the assembly who aren't
represented in the executive um they are
for minor parties um at present but do
you see an evolving space for
um more of uh and an opposition and then
I guess partly related to this we talked
about the exceptional circumstances in
Northern Ireland you know one of the
things that struck me during my time
um in the Northern Ireland office was
the extent to which um extends Way
Beyond storm and also into the role and
function of local government and and did
any of the panel looked at you know
whether there's more opportunity for
perhaps normalization in local
government than there might be in the
Stormwind
um structures
local government I think my impression
is I mean others much closer to the the
than me local government now operates
rather more effectively in Northern
Ireland because some councils ran a
rather majoritarian basis and
increasingly there has been a move
towards power sharing and that probably
permits them to be more effectively it
is still the case that in Northern
Ireland about 80 percent of voters vote
for parties that are drawn predominantly
from one or other section of the
community uh and that have a very
different different Outlook in principle
on the Constitutional Destiny of
Northern Ireland so you know we've not
moved too far away from the right now
there has been a a great growth of the
other category or whatever you want to
call them the center ground category and
at some stage the system I think will
need to if that continues we'll need to
adapt to accommodate that and you know
there there are points if for example a
person from that category became first
minister or Deputy first minute would
unbalance the system entirely uh now
ideally we should start having the
discussions about how to do that
and bring it into public debate
and on the point of a better opposition
I mean I think there's no problem in
having an opposition if it's a voluntary
opposition if you think so if people
choose to go into your position uh the
difficulties arrive arise if uh there's
a feeling of exclusion uh from some
parts of the community and I think you
can only
um
start to
tolerate that kind of circumstance if
the
the degree of
um
division within Society is less than it
is today
um
I think I'm going to Robin Walken now
are you on uh
no in which case I must be going to sort
of Buckland thank you very much indeed
um easy to confuse Robin and Robert
um I was trying to I was trying to
define the um
three Robertson Robin um
I'm
be careful and Dr hockey I think I could
echoed the point I made to Lord view
earlier about petitions of concern
um that there does seem to be
potentially a contradiction between new
decade new approach I think I think what
struck me about new decade new
approached it was that once again it was
um you know UK government ministers
bringing together the parties setting
out what looks like a very credible and
decent program for government but I
think the subtext of what you're saying
is that you know true peace is more than
an absence of conflict and it is
reflected by
political parties and think tanks coming
up with their own policies without
having the nio to help them do it
frankly that's not me being in any way
patronizing because I know there's there
are plenty of
you know people in in Northern Ireland
who've got lots of ideas and who want to
see policies homegrown policies brought
into into practice when do you think
we're going to get to that stage where
we can focus upon policy and not process
which
ditto still dominates the debate in a
way that I think a lot of people find
very alienating particularly people you
know on the ground who are trying to run
businesses or provide services
I I think it needs encouragement I think
there does need to be a culture change
and I think that the governments could
well take a role British government
particularly a new decade new approach
rightly and was focused on the economic
and social things that were going wrong
but generally the the prescription was
draw up more strategies uh now people
get rather cynical in Northern Ireland
about about straight one y guy I heard
remarks saying once we built ships
launched ships now we launch strategies
um launching a strategy doesn't actually
guarantee the things on the ground are
going to change and a lot of the failing
of the executive I think has been in the
follow-through they have you know they
they announce the planning outline but
then when it comes to the difficult
decisions often Health reform for
example uh that are involved in
implementation it rather falls falls
behind and you know there isn't the
great political Media or public pressure
on them to to keep doing these things so
I I floated in my my evidence the idea I
was involved in setting up the think
tank pivotal and that was very much uh
part of our mission to bring more Focus
onto onto onto uh public policy issues
and there may be room for for a
statutory body I'm a fiscal council is
doing
a lot of rather good work in in in
elucidating these issues and a body that
would would ventilate them
um bring them into public discussion
possibly draw up graph programs for
government and and longer term vision of
the program for government is only five
years
and and measure implementation which is
not to disk private think tanks because
I I think there is a scope for
encouraging uh a sort of mixed economy
there uh and uh and and a range of ideas
but I I do think sorry I've said this
before I think but I do think this is
essential to Future stability we we must
have a government that that delivers and
it will rise in public esteem and will
therefore be more difficult to topple
and and it may be less disheartening for
the people who are working in it as well
yes and and it's interesting to note
that sadly the Northern Ireland law
commission has not been operational for
nearly 10 years now and that's often a
generator of good law and law reform
that can be then taken on by by the
parties or on a cross party basis
could I just add in response to your
question that um one of the most
important requisites for
uh overcoming communalism sectarianism
is Trust
and we have been through a number of
years now that have not been very good
for trust
you know brexit clearly has uh whatever
you think brexit in itself has led to a
great distrust uh the actions around the
protocol
before the most recent ones uh uh led to
a great distrust and a sense of betrayal
um
the
you know speaking very frankly the
government in London is almost
universally what sorry the Johnson
government in London was almost
universally distrusted in Northern
Ireland
if that's the context it's very
difficult to start to
overcome these divisions
so a period of trust building and as
Alan says a strong Focus from London on
understanding its role in building trust
and ensuring that it's engaging
positively with all communities in
Northern Ireland and not treating
Northern Ireland as a
football for other
games
is fundamental to progress here I
strongly agree with that I mean it has
been as derived for what it's worth
um you know there was never perfect
trust in the British government people
were rarely um coming out in the three
to to to declare their admiration but
governments work very hard and of course
work very hard in with Dublin and the
the the the London Dublin partnership is
crew has been crucial to political
advance and I think we still handle it
to help Drive political advance so those
are areas that I think really do need
serious remedial work
um
talking about
possible ability of reforming
institutions
how do you think
government of Northern Ireland could be
reformed to make it more stable
another question yeah
um you can you can answer this in three
words only
Dr hockey do you want to kick off
I mean it depends on the extent of
despite the assumption that you could
someone might agree to reform it you
know we're making this slightly
assumption so how could it be made
better
well there is strong public support for
reform of the institution so I was
involved in two research projects one
was a kind of quantitative survey public
opinion the other one was a mini public
and we that both of those projects
touched on institutional reform and if I
had have been um in conversation with
Lord beer later on when he was
essentially saying you know we can't
perform the institutions because the dep
and Champion won't Delight
the public disagree
public don't agree with that
there is strong in the public pardon
particularly younger public there's
strong cross community consensus that
these institutions need reform that
consensus kind of dissipates when you
ask about the extent of that reform so
whenever we kind of Dove down into these
issues with our our many public
um last year
the first part of the day
people had very
many criticisms of the institutions and
had didn't have a lot of good things to
say about mandatory correlation but in
the second half of the citizens assembly
we explained the kind of basics of a
more voluntary coalition
and that did make some people anxious
people who previously in the earlier
part of the day were very critical of
monetary Coalition when we said well
what about the prospect of a voluntary
Coalition we're anxious about that idea
and we're asking well is there going to
be cross community Sea Of Cards give me
these people the
fundamentally younger people
the key reform they would want is so
that government cannot be put into the
cupboard and you know so the key reform
they want is you cannot have stormonts
suspended
and government has got to go on so
that's presumably the First Reform they
they would want I assume
a removal of of the video I think it's
in the current circumstances it's it's
easy to make that case there will be
political resistance to it as lordview
said and there absolutely will be
um resistance to that but that's not to
say that removing that fatal means
removing all of the safeguards that we
could put in to ensure you know equality
between the communities
um we can reform the system and keep
mandatory Coalition so there's tinkering
around the edges that we could do
um so if you I think this was raised in
a few evidence submission submitted to
the committee if you threw in the first
Minister and Deputy first minister with
the hunt
rather than the process that we use now
so that if it was chosen by the hunt in
the dep or shinfin said we don't want to
nominate the opportunity we just passed
to the next qualifying party so that
might resolve that issue
um and that is the primary critique of
the primary concern that people have
with the institutions when we ask people
in our mini citizens assembly what do
you not like about it it was about
Ransom politics and instability and at
the end of the day we ask people what is
it that you want most from your
government and people might think that
they would say reform of the NHS or
better Public Services by Far and Away
people said stability
I'm not just could you say that again
stability they said they want visibility
and that's pretty basic expectation of
one's government but such has been the
instability that that's what people are
crying out for
and existence
ability and being in existence is what
you mean yeah
includes having a government in place
the work that's incentive for that I
mean I I I I think Mrs writing in his
sort of question and again sort of
highlighting on the youth but
whilst the main unionist party and the
main nationalist party control
I mean potentially on a greater pendulum
effect
but you know do very well out of this
system
Top Dog and second top dog or joint Top
Dog
there's no incentive for them to change
is there
why would you break the model that
rewards you
or change the model I mean break is a
break is the more change the model
evolve the model
which may see you possibly be on the
opposition benches
sorry
which is why I think but you know we we
need more discussion of the
possibilities here uh and I think
increasing the the increasing vote for
Center ground parties uh other parties
May well reflect that sort of would you
think it was it was better for the
Secretary of State
to convene
discussions around this rather than
respond to requests if one if one
accepts the if we're doing frankly well
out of this let's not bother changing it
because we might not do as well as we
are
well look I think in present
circumstances and the Secretary of State
probably has slightly more urgent things
to do than together but
no but the I think we need to start the
discussion on how the system May evolve
and from that pressure may may begin to
emerge to do it on the question about
how you restore stability
generally that that is a very big
question I don't think the answers are
primarily institutional it is about
culture it is about they suggested uh
you know restoring some of the hope and
momentum of the agreement and the other
things that the agreement
was focused on promoting reconciliation
dealing with the past and so forth those
underpinnings which are really vital to
stability ensuring policing by consent
really need to be to be looked at again
and progress has stalled uh and the
public has become to some degree more
disenchanted and needs to be revived on
the question what you should do to break
Deadlocks I mean it's very difficult to
do quite do institutional reform in in
it I think other than by by cross party
consensus because you know the agreement
was uh was agreed by a large measure of
consensus and and approved in
referendums but if the deadlock
continues then I think there is a strong
case for the government on a temporary
basis at least to decide on changes to
the institutions to permit government to
go on because there is no agreement
compliant method of delivering
government if the institutions don't
don't function as a present and it it I
I come back to this point it is
absolutely essential that government is
done uh and the civil servants can't do
it they can't deal with the longer term
issues so I I if you know after the
local government elections perhaps we
don't quite quickly get back to
government I think the uh to a devolved
government I think there is a strong
case for tweaks to permit the
institutions to resume with some parties
in in in in in in opposition while
discussion goes on about about longer
term uh uh reform
I I just don't think I've just been
looking at messages coming through from
the whips office votes are expected
shortly
um I think we're expecting three votes
um but I'm quite Keen to do
um if we can if we can't we'll come back
but just to try and draw this to a
conclude this session this panel session
to a conclusion
um a couple of minutes after the Bell
has run okay rather than keeping you
three waiting and and everything else so
I'm going to Robin had you tried to yes
I mean it was just honestly sorry
forgive me Bob had you finished yes okay
thank you uh Robin and it it was just on
this point of possible reform we were
talking about before coalitions of the
Willing being talked about in the past
and and so on so forth Arrangements
forward the current Arrangements clearly
do in some way discriminate in favor of
the two main groups versus those who
designate themselves as I other and we
have seen that other group emerge as a
stronger force in in Northern Irish
politics at the same time we've seen the
concept of Northern Ireland identity
growing
um versus people who identify as Irish
or British and so is there an argument
from that perspective about looking at
um
offering greater influence two parties
that designate as other and allowing for
reforms that would
give them a greater role in the
structure whilst maintaining some degree
of balance I think to the point of Alan
renick has made about the importance of
having a balance built into the
structure
well I think they're absolutely very
strong Arguments for for that in in
principle the politics of doing it is is
is is different but I mean the the
agreement is basically you know founded
on the Assumption there are two tribes
in Northern Ireland and this is all that
really matters
um and and you know we have moved on
from that quite substantially and the
voting rules in the assembly clearly
discriminate they don't give the veto
rights to to to to to to people from the
center ground now what you do about it
is is without create even greater
obstacles to decision making uh within
government within the assembly is is is
a more a more complicated question uh
but it's one that should certainly be
addressed but but on the on the the
processor Robin I think and this is kind
of speaks to the previous question as
well there is a little hanging fruit
here in terms of getting keeping this
conversation going but in different
cases we've come back to this idea of
reforms may be desirable but there won't
be the political that will alerted to
implement them
the government could establish the Civic
advisory panel that all of the parties
wanted with new decade new approach and
then it it fell by the way he said
because covid took over
um that would be showing Fidelity to the
Good Friday agreement there was a Civic
form and the Good Friday agreement that
was allowed to weather on the vine and
then the European Champion didn't want
to re-establish it again that is as much
a part of a good Friday agreement as all
of the other bits and pieces so you
could establish this government could
could establish the Civic advisory panel
as a standalone body that exists with or
without the devolved institutions and
they can keep this conversation going
and speak with the public to find out
how much appetite there is for various
degrees of institutional reform and the
final thing I'll say on that is
um
Professor remicks absolutely right that
consortiational power sharing systems
are very difficult to change but they
are changeable we have had institutional
reforms of our system over the years we
used to have 100 mlas now we have 90 we
didn't used to have Provisions for an
opposition now we do I was reading a
book the other day by an academic called
Camille bedok who wrote this
um excellent book about institutional
engineering and even systems that look
very very concrete and immovable they
can change they usually change when the
reform is bottom up when it's it's
there's pressure from Below
that confronts the the reluctance
um at the political Elite level and
we've we've reached the end of the road
of reforming our institutions by
political leaders some of the time are
those reforms if you think of Saint
Andrews they've had unintended
consequences because it's left to party
political leaders to kick up behind
closed doors I think we've reached the
end of the road for that we need to
establish mechanisms for civic Society
to have a a significant voice in this
um and unless that happens we're not
going to get institutional reform
because there's too many people that
benefit out of the current system
so can I just say yes please I
completely agree with that but at the
same time you cannot use these sorts of
processes to circumvent politicians
and political parties and the need to
build consensus across the parties uh
you know the the fact that and we don't
have the dep or the origin fan in the
room presently they both clearly matter
a great deal
um and you you these kinds of processes
can help the process of the process of
the parties coming together and need to
be designed carefully in order to enable
that
but they can't be used to just try to
get past the crisis and absolutely
exactly they'd matter a great deal and
you have to have the engagement of of
both the as traditions and indeed the
key parties
um but it's not inconceivable that
within the next few years we could be in
a situation in which those are no longer
the two biggest parties um in the
assembly and if the one of the biggest
parties in the assembly were one which
did not identify with one of the major
Traditions then there's a clear case at
that point that you have to have reform
of the institutions that would allow it
to the things to function possibly I
guess the question is partly should talk
some conversations and Civic dialogue be
attempting to preempt that or should
people be waiting until that happens
well no we should certainly be
discussing that uh as I said and just to
end all Sean's point I think it is very
important to bring Civic Society into
the discussion more about this but about
about a wide range of issues
um I I having tried to sort of engage
people in various initiatives over the
years because successfully with pivotal
less successfully than others there is a
strong resistance among a lot of people
outside politics I think to putting
their heads above the parapet because at
times they got them chewed off by
politicians they've all politicians and
those are people often with uh great
influence great large ass at their
disposal so it becomes you know if
you're a leader of a business you will
hesitate to to pipe up and say no that's
wrong the governments could could
provide forums whatever the
institutional form uh in which that is
encouraged rather more and I think you
know at times that has been a very
positive force
um and you know forces for encouraging
constructive politics at the moment are
rather missing
okay let's turn out Claire Hannah thank
you very much and this has been really
interesting and enjoyed your your your
submissions as well a nice afternoon of
nerding out to to build on your uh
earlier I mean um just picking up on on
what bulb and Robin were asking I mean I
happen to think the the core defects and
on the sort of most urgent areas for
Action are around veto and general
disincentive uh to compromise including
those issues around this and Andrews
changes and the privatization at first
Minister elections and all that
um uh but I I I I do think symbolically
at least the the designation is is is
problematic I have that's new I think I
remember when I was a new MLA Sean doing
an interview with the other boy 2015
about exactly this and and while I I'll
always take the opportunity to reiterate
an adult saying people are saying it in
this room but it is not regressive or uh
Arash optional to have a view on the
Constitutional issue and certainly while
the UK has been having this tremendous
meltdown and the Republic of Ireland
um is is booming it is certainly
rational and Northern Ireland isn't
working
um uh for for people to want to pursue
that so so I would separate the symbolic
Act of you know dividing into sheep and
goats as your very first thing you do
um as an MLA with with the the the the
perfect validity of having
constitutional views but I think it is
um essentially bad crack and I think it
puts people off and I think it just
foregrounds uh constitutional and indeed
process issues so um I I'm I'm
interested in how you
um
think we would step away from that
because somebody used the analogy
earlier about pulling a thread and and
all that and it's not just as simple
maybe as deleting it out
um because obviously
um that has implications we have
advocated and put down amendments on the
mepoc bill uh Rowan looking at say
two-thirds thresholds and qualified
majorities and all that sort of stuff as
alternatives to
um to to the wearing so I just wonder
how you think you should we would
address that you you sat on a boat you
know it is discriminated against because
it doesn't have a video to me the way to
address that is to level down take the
video off others rather than uh add the
video that that's the way so I I think
there's almost too much focus on it but
also
um it is worth
um it it is still worth um at the very
least toning down and the impact of
designation and I'm interested in how
you think we would do that would you we
would who would particularly like to do
that one it's not straightforward as
people say you know there will be a
great deal of institutional resistance I
suppose from the two main parties assume
that's that's like that sorry I just I
just wanted to clarify we've got to come
on can I just can I finish my point
we've got to come on to the process but
let's not start the conversation with
deviant family so we can't let's talk
about how it should would happen and
then we can get on too but that is why I
perhaps rather feebly earlier suggested
the starting point is at least to have
more public discussion more expert
because you know the the experts on the
institutional questions generally tend
to be people within the institutions or
within parties uh not really within
Academia there has been quite little
public discussion and we could usefully
have have more of that and more ideas
ventilated and then you know they may
acquire a political
a a a a political impetus of their own
the other thing is of course the
political crisis is the time when these
things may happen I I was suggesting you
we we may I I think it is an imperative
to get the institutions back up and
running in some form quite soon because
lots of government isn't being done
other long-term damage is very serious
and the absence of of government
completely is you know traditionally the
absence of politics a political vacuum
has always been bad for all sorts of
reasons and doesn't want to talk them up
but they are there there is potentially
a benign a malign scenario in which we
lose slowly over time a lot of the gains
of the of the agreement if the
institutions can't come back so I would
argue that it is important to bring them
back in some form and I say there are
legitimacy issues over that so you would
do it temporarily while you you continue
then to have discussions with the
parties about how to how to move forward
but those might be institutions you know
with a and I suggested in in the paper I
think there would be an argument there
because you would have to set up a
government that would be able to get its
business through the assembly the
obvious way to move is in fact towards a
weighted majority threshold system uh
and have that running on a temporary
basis for both selection formation of
the executive and for votes within it
and in that way you might get an
executive of reason it's still
reasonably representative politically
crucial whether you get the up and if
the dup were were intent on staying out
but which could then operate as an
executive and could carry its business
through uh this all assuming the dep
doesn't
so you mean basically and I and I am
kind of assuming that we
we're doing this from a place of
restoration I always think of that Homer
Simpson it's been X days since our last
disaster so even even if and when
hopefully we we come back this this
spring
um looking at these you think you need
to transition uh obviously there's no
question that we would have designation
go on before
um
how do you how do you still manage power
sharing on Executive formation
um if people aren't designating is what
I'm asking is their way well I I was I'm
sorry this was writing the other way
around it's if we don't get the dup
coming yeah
institutions then I think there would be
a good case for a a government in which
designation did not apply so you would
you would have some sort of majority
voting system before securing at least
the top jobs the fmdfm I daringly
suggested that actually if you're moving
away from there there is a case for
three joint first ministers uh which at
least gets you you know which sounds
absurd but I mean I'm trying well in a
sense the absurdity is moving away from
having one leader of a government isn't
it and once you've got there having to
suggest once you've got two Microsoft
three well my wife and I had the same
discussion about children so there was
there is um there is form on this for
everybody in the audience
say you are completely representative of
a community because I mean ultimately
the the first Muslim reprovestments have
uh at the moment a veto effectively over
over
um difficult to say you're completely
representative of all groups in society
but that's that's another question but
you you would have a way to majority
system for selecting them and Away to
majority system therefore them to get
their their key votes through the
assembly otherwise you know the the the
the the the party staying out if
sufficiently large could stymie uh or
government it is very important we get
government with an agenda and the
carries through the necessary reforms
at a minimum just kind of
following on from what Alan was saying I
think and and Professor romance
absolutely right that you know we can't
particularly with the with power
steering government we can't step over
political leaders as frustrating as the
videos may be reforming the system
without political buy-in from them you
know the new system won't have
legitimacy
um the dep fought the election they
wouldn't go back into the executive
until the protocol was resolved to their
satisfaction fair enough
what we could think about is as a
a minimum is reforming the route for
electing a speaker so that the weighted
majority cross community voting rules
apply for everything else but for a
speaker we kind of lack the speaker by a
simplified super majority say 65 so if
that had happened we would have had a
speaker in May because Patsy McGlone got
71 support that included support from
unionist Nationals and others
are not crucially would have meant that
the assembly would have been able to
form the committee system would have
been able to form
and we wouldn't have had caretaker
ministers in office without organized
accountability mechanisms mechanisms
holding into account that's just an
untenable people think that caretaker
ministers don't have any power that's
nonsense they don't have any new power
but they were in office for six months
or thereabouts with no assembly to hold
them to account so there's a democratic
case for reforming just the rule for
electing speaker so that we can have an
assembly for when we don't have
Executives but we do have a caretaker
Minister I reckon we've got
every four minutes yeah oh we've got
three we've got well we've got three for
what it's worth uh you may be aware
we've normally made that proposal about
the speaker we've written to the
secretary
are engaging with those who who wish to
engage you briefly touched on on the
public opinion maybe you could just
clarify what we do know about that you
know kind of can you can you quantify it
you know the the percentage and
obviously it it it's only pulling and
focus grouping or or whatever but how
substantial that is and how you think it
would be good to approach it bear in
mind that you know the agreement was
broadly negotiated and endorsed by the
people and for example the changes at St
Andrews Mills were done over the heads
of the people as well as over some of
the parties so so so so those who would
get keep haven't been that purest about
inclusion uh to date but um so with that
idea of bottom up essentially of
demonstrating the weight of public
opinion and essentially nudging some of
the the more recalcitrant uh uh
interests how substantial is our public
opinion um how do you think is it should
be approached what would be the next
steps to building the case for reform
okay
um so on the question of whether the
institution should be reformed I think
about 65 to 70 percent of the people are
in favor of institutional reform now
we're limited by survey questions in
terms if you can't make them too
complicated you lose people
um The Institute of Irish studies had a
survey last year
um about how the reform process should
come about 72 percent of people thought
that there should be a Citizens assembly
first or a series of citizens assemblies
to kind of Flesh that out
um and then about 80 of people thought
that you know when this is eventually
flashed out that there should be a
referendum on it referendum needs to be
at the very very end of a very long and
deliberative process that has political
buy-in and so people there's a public
appetite out there for discussions about
institutional reform when we in the
citizens assembly talked about voluntary
correlation most people thought that
Northern Ireland was not yet ready for a
voluntary Coalition and wanted some
safeguards and if you have safeguards
then sometimes that necessitates
designation plus if we use cross if
we're using cross community votes for
the for the storm might break this might
be baked in and locked in for a while
anyway yeah yeah
it's one of those things people like the
sound of but that's what I'm saying when
you actually start to unpick it I think
and there's anybody's got some burning
pithy three Burger to come in I would
just say remember that they're a
minority communities that will find this
kind of thing very hard and they need to
be thought of as well of a recession
that's taken us from high nerdery
through to Homer Simpson
can I thank our panel second panel this
afternoon thank you for taking our
questions you've given us a lot to think
about order order